Oh
[Music]
my name is April Bloomfield over at
Salvation burger on 51st and third so I
wanted to create the perfect burger so I
tried to dive into each component so how
we make the patties the grind you know
from the buns to the special source to
the pickles to the fries all those I
have total control over and it's very
well balanced you know you want just
enough pickle to kind of cut through all
that fat and cheese or like the beer
cheese you need just enough fear to kind
of cut through the fat of the burger and
the fats and the cheese so balance is
like super important
so the way we cook the salvation burger
is all over would I like doing the
secretary over the woods because it
gives the time for the sweetness of the
wood and the smokes kind of a such an
idea to the ax patties the reason why we
constantly flip is to make sure that the
grade
if the cooking is nice and even so
hopefully you don't end up with those
kind of like unappealing gray areas on
the outside of the burger you know good
caramelization good saltiness kind of
concentrated you know after it's been
cooking on the grill a little bit and
then you get this little slow
it's about fat ratio we're kind of
looking from a 70/30 kind of ratio so 17
kind of dense protein 230 you know pure
fat or sometimes we range from 80 to 20
this depends you know SATs flavor so
having a good amount of fat is really
important in a burger and it also gives
it the feeling of being once you know as
kind of a certain juiciness to it so
getting that fat kind of protein ratio
is super super important if you want to
make the perfect burger
you